what we were joking about before where
he was like in his song yeah where he
was you know basically joking about like
[ __ ] his sister or whatever or what
was it again
you know I was like I see you want to
[ __ ] my best friend talking about Brent
Rivera by the way guys
Brent Rivera yeah so he did this new
YouTube video where like his his
solution to the quarantine content
problem yeah is to throw his sister is
missing her promise so he wants to throw
a prom for her right and her date he
gets to dance with her
yeah oh my god no no I mean like I don't
know I didn't watch that much and do it
but like you know this could be this
could be construed as like or this could
be looked at as like this is a cute
thing to do for your sister is a very
nice thing but if you think about our
bit and the song that I bore yeah it
could be like damn I'm just trying to
see my sister and my friend surprise him
and my sister with it this is some weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] man it's weird it's it's a
little bit weird it's creepy dude keep
that on for a second oh right keep it on
for this one's that guy YouTube channel
I don't know about you guys but I have
been very bored over this whole
quarantine stay inside this you know
dudes Jesse you man just you
oh no wait wait no it is everybody in
the [ __ ] world that's also bored you
guys I don't know you guys man but I've
been really bored with this whole
quarantine thing every [ __ ] delivery
driver truck driver warehouse person has
to put a forklift through this kids
[ __ ] face who else is bored during
this [ __ ] a pandemic thing I I think
it's funny because no 50% of people like
are are at home right now and our board
and it's just the most basic it's like
naming your [ __ ] thing quarantine
team or whatever yeah yeah who
else is bored right now is it even a
question that's what that's where I feel
like that in 2020 youtube intros just
need to go away yeah like setting [ __ ]
up nah just no more just out no no no
more that's like today my sister now
just [ __ ] do the thing yeah yeah go
right to the prom right to the prom just
cut to it yeah yeah throwing my sister
off the balcony play wow you did it so I
don't know about you guys but I've been
kind of scared of getting the corona
virus so I'm going out in public and I'm
kissing people on the lips to see if I
can get it all right I wanna see but the
actual video starts for him creating the
[ __ ] I'm sure if you go through this
whole video too I'm sure he talks about
this [ __ ] like it's dumb normal and all
his friends are in the shot like uh yeah
totally look at that look at that shot
right there oh yeah well let's play this
part obviously school club is your
senior year and I know you were missing
prom this year because of it so and I
know you were missing out on potentially
losing your virginity with my sister so
I want to make sure that happens I wanna
make sure you boink my sister so I've
actually killed our parents and I've
ensured that you have a private evening
tonight I've put Molly and everything
because I want you guys to be definitely
in the mood and you know get in their
sport and in a way we go here's the
thing bro prom in your house is not this
is not yeah gonna compare yes you too
it's not like all your friends are in
that [ __ ]
and I you know the gesture I'm sure you
know the gesture is nice well let's see
how it goes it would have been a nice
gesture if there wasn't a [ __ ] camera
in their face the whole time
right right trying to have it have their
dance or whatever
mm-hmm any just like I yeah let's see
yeah why are you doing this dude this is
weird
[Laughter]
that's the best part of the whole video
are you joking me bro oh yeah last
person I would do this
well the [ __ ] you doing this man this is
a completely out of character for you
man
you never do nice [ __ ] like this well
the [ __ ] are you doing this man this is
weird the brother he's like trying to
still like hold you know hold the nice
face cuz he's being films why the [ __ ]
you doing this bro kind of camera in the
rose petals and there's like thanks but
it's kind of weird why'd you say that
text about I hope you get lucky tonight
that was [ __ ] weird I gotta see what
happens next goddamn that even his
[ __ ] sister is like what the [ __ ] is
even going on here enhance she's looking
at her mom like mom did you okay this
and she's like yeah I mean Brent's got
done [ __ ] earlier you imagine the
[ __ ] in just stone silence from an ex
man look so pretty she's [ __ ]
cleaning out bottles of [ __ ] Apothic
red yeah she's [ __ ] refilling her
[ __ ] Zanic subscription
yes trying to figure out how she can go
there without a [ __ ] mask pictures
and now it is time to go inside the
house guys and experience profit when T
is like look at this [ __ ] it's like
hurry this [ __ ] up man hurry up bro
we're trying to drink yeah
turn off oh my [ __ ] dude oh my if you
know you lit if you know you if you know
his day he just Oh bro was he bout to do
a little commencement make a little
speech it is time now for you guys to
consummate the prom king and queen
please follow me upstairs and begin the
consummate celebration
it's [ __ ] up but it has that energy
man yeah this got big incest vibes big
incest vibes bro did he buy her that
dress to like what the [ __ ] time for the
slow song oh man he made him do it
Oh [ __ ] weird oh man alright get your
hands off my sister if there's only yeah
there's only one person who can hold my
sister like that and it's me yo so I
don't know about you guys but I'm
attracted to my sister and so did the
scoring team has made me realize how
much I want to bang my sister
and I'm bored what about you guys
[ __ ] hell
yeah I'm bored but what was that first
one oh I'm just bored and I want to [ __ ]
my sister
[Laughter]
you